it's great to welcome back to the
program Ralph Nader who is a political
activist consumer advocate former
presidential candidate and also author
most recently of the book how the rats
reformed the Congress you can get the
book and find out much more about it at
rats reform Congress org it's so great
to have you back on I appreciate it
thank you it's rats reform Congress yes
so let's talk a little bit about the
idea behind the book and and how it
relates to real-world activism because
just to give you some context I have
been talking for a long time on my
program about calling your elected
officials is great signing petitions on
the Internet
I don't know really how much it does but
it's a show of support but that at a
certain point there may need to be
something closer to a real revolt by the
population if we are to change some of
the systemic problems that exist with
our system of government and our country
can you talk about that idea of a revolt
and sort of how you tell that story in
the book sure basically it starts out
with a rat infestation and on Capitol
Hill and there is actually a rat
infestation throughout Washington DC and
the rats do what rats do they go for
water and food they don't have any
answer for more for quality like Mickey
Mouse and they find that one of the best
venues is to go up the pipes into the
toilet bowls of the members of Congress
and you can imagine the horror on
discovering this by the Speaker of the
House and a Minority Leader of the House
and they try to cover it up while they
try to deal with the rat infestation
scurrying all over the offices and a
reporter exposes it and then all the
press goes wild and making jokes of that
making rat jokes making jokes of the
politician late-night comedy TV derision
spreads all over the country and people
start paying some attention to the
Congress
and some active groups and people who
weren't active said hey let's take
advantage of this while people are
looking at the Congress and the
spectacle on national TV and social
media let's mobilize the people and the
rest of the book after making you laugh
yourself seriously is how Congress rat
watcher groups they're really Congress
watchdog groups can be easily formed in
every congressional district and how
mass rallies around Capitol Hill that go
on for hours with bullhorns demanding
the resignation of the corporate law
makers and starting to get defectors
from the 535 men and women who have so
much of our power and some of them
defect and join the crowd in the
meantime a very representative group of
really serious citizens run by a former
stonemason is developing the agenda and
the congressional hearings and they
learn that the faster reform is proposed
instead of being drawn out the quicker
each reform helps each other and builds
more and more support so if some people
are interested in living wage but
they're not interested in full Medicare
for all they support fill Medicare for
all and vice versa and a lot of these
changes are long overdue they have huge
polling support which means liberals and
conservatives support as they do now a
full Medicare for all at living wage law
enforcement against corporate crime
against consumers and workers and the
environment and defenseless communities
bad trade agreements dealing with the
enormous ly bloated corporate welfare
budget which is draining away from
investment in repairing America at the
community level you know the usual list
schools highways bridges public transit
sewage drinking water systems are
crumbling and huge Public Works programs
will create good-paying jobs that can't
be exported to China and they will
improve public services
now who is against that I mean the
Chamber of Commerce locally is for the
labor unions are for everybody
supports these kinds of renovations and
repairs and upgrades so this book which
is not that long
it is funny in places where it should be
but in humor there is truth but it gives
you a tremendous level of excitement
because again and again as the people
are mobilizing and taking back control
of Congress after all they delegated the
power to this tiny branch of government
that has the most powerful impact
because it's it's empowered by the
Constitution to be more powerful than
the executive and judicial branch as the
taxing power the spending power the
confirmation of nominees to the
judiciary power has a word declaring
power has the investigatory power yeah
and so so people are saying let's take
back control and every for every move
and a lot of creative moves that people
say hey we can do that every move meets
one test which is can anybody stop you
the people from doing that well I mean
let's let me dig into that a little bit
so in the if you imagine in the real
world what would be in your view a
realistic trigger for this sort of level
of civil disobedience and revolt that in
the book you you sort of fictionalized
but it's very prescient in terms of the
real world and the context for me asking
that question is part of the problem
with the system we have is that with
stagnant wages with it being so easy to
get fired because most jobs don't have
any kind of contractual or union
protection all of the things that you
know and have been talking about it's a
system that's designed to make it really
hard for people to say we are going to
execute a sustained period of revolt and
civil disobedience and mass gathering so
what what would be big enough to trigger
that first of all you got to have a
different attitude stop using the words
resistance and civil disobedience and
start using word
takeover of Congress you have so many
people around the country marches
demonstrations on climate disruption on
bigotry on civil rights etc and they
lose all this energy that goes into the
ether on a weekend when the
demonstrations occur and it isn't
refocused on your two senators and
representatives where you summon them to
your own people's town meetings and
place the agenda of legislation and
repeal of bad laws on their table you
see they come to listen to you and they
look over the crowd in the auditorium
and they say hey this is just
conservatives here the Liberals here how
do I game this one this is going to be
rather difficult and so what this book
starts out with are the long overdue
improvements and livelihoods that people
in Western Europe and Canada I've had
for decades so it starts out with the
living wage you have 45 million workers
in this country make less than 15 bucks
an hour before deductions you can't live
on that mm-hm so that that's that's a
big mobilizer
for this book in this book the second is
pull Medicare fraud well you know the
progressives even presses they don't
know how to argue this they argue it in
terms of fairness in terms of health
care they don't say 35,000 people die
every year because it can't afford
health insurance to get diagnosed and
treated in time they don't say that the
system is so corrupt that according to
the leading experts in the field three
hundred and fifty billion dollars every
year goes down the drain and
computerized billing fraud and abuse in
a health care area that's three hundred
and fifty billion with a B so all these
elaborations show people how to argue
their case much better and then of
course there's a double standard of
justice you don't think the guy in the
bar knows that one one standard for
people and a double standard for
corporations and corporate executives
who get off they don't get criminally
prosecuted for preventable deaths and
injuries and the workplace in the
environment and
hospital malpractice etc and so that's
another very popular one law and order
crime and sweets has to be addressed the
fourth one is how come these big
corporations are on the dole why are
they subsidized by your tax dollars
Frank those tax dollars should be
brought back to you in terms of jobs
repairing public services in your
community
as I noted earlier the same thing with
the tax system you have students that
now is 1.5 trillion dollars and what
kind of society launches its young
generation and a sea of debt you tell me
what kind of society no country in
Western Europe does that you have
tuition free education and most of these
countries for free college or university
and so well how do you get rid of
student debt well you know we bailed out
Wall Street that trillions of dollars in
2008 I say we because nobody asked the
taxpayer was forced down their throat by
the via the Bush and Obama
administration Citigroup Bank of America
all these crooks they were billed out so
why not have a jubilee for student debt
well who's going to pay for that it's
simple you have a Wall Street
speculation tax hey Americans don't you
go into stores and pay six seven eight
percent sales tax on things you need to
buy yeah well how come there's no sales
tax if today someone buys a hundred
million dollars of Exxon's bonds or
Exxon derivatives
how about a sales tax of a say a half a
percent that's pretty small that's 300
billion dollars mr. Packard so it's all
these things that really rile people's
sense of unfairness and the double
standard and corporations being our
masters instead of being our servants
and we the people and the sovereignty
the people making sure that they
delegate their power with strings
attached to Congress and if you take
control Congress the ball game starts to
be over and that's what most
progressives don't understand that like
the Occupy Wall Street you know they
trespassed
they got a lot of press because they
took over Zuccotti Park right and other
places around the country but they
didn't have an issue so I had a
conference called with 300 of them and I
said here's your issue it's a living
wage they said of course I said well why
don't you occupy the space around all
your congressional representatives you
got all the people ready to go and said
well we can't organize anything in other
words they blew this huge opportunity in
2011 yeah with mass media focus day
after day and it didn't focus on the one
institution that can make it happen and
that's why it's got to be it's the
Congress people it's the Congress view
they got to get that drilled in their
head there are only 535 of them and on
many issues you got about a hundred and
fifty on your side from the get-go and
the one thing every member of Congress
wants more than corporate campaign
contributions is your vote but if your
vote is an uninformed vote a
stay-at-home vote an unfocused around
agenda reform vote your vote doesn't
mean much this is what this rap book is
all about people are ordering five
copies at a time mr. Packard because I
think they're discussing it in their
living room if they go to rats reform
Congress orgy they can not only get the
book but they can access free a tutorial
about how to set up these Congress
watchdog groups right and it's no big
deal
and nobody can stop you from doing it
and it's a lot easier than you think and
it takes less than 1% of people to turn
Congress around on issue after issue as
long as they are supported by majority
opinion the book is fantastic it's
called how the rats reformed the
Congress we've been speaking with the
book's author and very very longtime
activist Ralph Nader Ralph thank you as
always for being on the program well
thank you for intelligent programming
and I think your listeners would love
the covers by mr. fish who's a great
cartoonist out of Philadelphia it's a
spectacular cover and on the back are
you're arguing points on the critique of
Congress and what has to be done the
most concise critique
Congress ever put on one page